hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions Oxford
ranks as one of the top universities in
the world a version of this problem was
used as an Oxford interview question a
ladder is placed vertically on a wall
what shape does the midpoint of the
ladder trace as the ladder slides
against the wall to the floor what if
the ladder instead fell backwards to the
ground by rotating from its base what
shape would the midpoint of the ladder
trace then can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for a solution
so how can we solve this problem well it
sometimes helps in problems like these
to sketch out a few cases and get some
intuition of what the answer might be so
let's place this ladder vertically on
the wall and consider the path of its
midpoint we can imagine the ladder
sliding against the wall and we'll keep
track of where the midpoint of this
ladder goes eventually we'll get some
idea of what this path is now focusing
just on the midpoints we might guess
that this shape is a quarter circle but
Oxford interviews just like my videos
are about more than getting just the
correct answer it's about demonstrating
your ability to think and approve the
answer so can we prove that the path is
a quarter circle well in order to do
that let's go back to our sketch and
consider one position of the ladder
let's write L for the length of the
ladder above and below the midpoint will
be L over two because we have half the
ladders length in each direction now
consider these two right triangles
because they have the same angles and
their hypotenuse has the same length
these two right triangles are congruent
to each other so they will have X as
their horizontal length and Y as the
vertical length now the midpoint will be
X comma Y in a coordinate system now
looking at either triangle we can use
the Pythagorean theorem to get x squared
plus y squared is equal to the quantity
L over 2 squared this equation is very
well-known in this case the midpoint
traces out a quarter circle in the
positive quadrant with the radius that's
half the latter's length and this is the
proof of why the path is a quarter
circle but there's nothing quite like
seeing it for yourself so here's an
animation that I made on desmos comm and
you can see that the midpoint of the
ladder
exactly traces out B path
a quarter-circle as it slides against
the wall so now let's consider the
second problem which is the ladder
falling away from the wall like before
let's sketch each of these cases and get
an idea for the path of the midpoint now
looking at this path we might once again
guess that it's a quarter circle but can
we prove it well in this case it's a
little bit easier the midpoint will
always be a distance of L over two from
the corner of the wall in the ground so
you can imagine that's the same distance
and therefore it's a quarter circle but
we can also prove it like in the first
case where we use the Pythagorean
theorem and we get exactly the same
equations as before to show that this
midpoint also traces out the path of a
quarter circle so once again seeing is
also satisfying so here's an animation
that's made with desmos calm to show
that the midpoint traces out the path of
a quarter circle as the ladder Falls
away from the wall and we now have a
rather curious result both cases show
the same path of the midpoint so here's
another animation that puts both ladders
in the same graph and you'll see the
midpoint of each ladder is along this
quarter circle so amazingly both cases
result in the same path of a quarter
circle now obviously in real life the
sliding ladder will be slower due to its
friction against the wall in the ground
this animation is just to show why the
paths of the midpoints are the same
shape a geometric way that you can see
this is that the two ladders represent
the diagonals of a rectangle and they
will intersect at this midpoint of the
two ladders you can also see this as the
pivot point of a scissor lift so it's
quite amazing
that in either case the midpoint of the
ladder is tracing out the same quarter
circle did you figure it out thanks for
watching these math videos which can be
watched for free on YouTube inspire and
build confidence for people around the
world and they have over a hundred
million views please subscribe for free
to get the newest videos and email me a
puzzle or math topic presh and mind your
decisions comm if you so choose you can
check out my merchandise on teespring
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support